a well-known problem that has arisen
, shelling continues, civilians are dying,
neo-Nazis are using openly
terrorist methods of sabotage at
life support facilities, they are
attempting to assassinate representatives of local
authorities in the Donetsk People's
Republic of the Luhansk People's Republic,
as well as the Kherson and Zaporozhye
regions, before they became part of
Russia, martial
law was in effect And now we  it is necessary
to formalize this regime already within the framework of
Russian legislation, therefore,
a decree was signed on the introduction of martial
law in these four constituent entities of the
Russian Federation. In addition, the
current situation, I consider it necessary
to give additional powers to the
leaders of all Russian regions, the
corresponding decree was also signed today.
implementation of measures
designed to ensure the safety of people, the
protection and anti-terrorist
protection of critically important
maintenance facilities  In the absence of public order,
not only the
relevant law enforcement agencies and the entire
system of public administration are engaged in solving the problems of ensuring a special military operation, it is
necessary to continue work to
improve coordination in this
regard, the government will prepare a draft
presidential decree on the establishment of a special
coordination council,
it will be headed by the head of the cabinet of the minister, the
composition of the council will include deputy prime ministers
representatives of law enforcement agencies of the
socio-economic bloc of the
government of the administration of the president of the
state council